it's time to make the annual green bean
casserole mom what ingredients do in
eight great means and casserole let's do
that student let's put the green beans
in the pan no no it looks like seaweed
we are using French style green bean
French style because we're cultural
issues we're going international this is
made with natural sea salt you can it
looks like it came directly from the sea
look we're halfway done we're almost
good now what now we need some cream of
mushroom soup I can't eat this good hurt
my butthole oh you can well I mean I'm
gonna have it I'm safe in a house we do
not need all this I hope that I don't
want to eat like half of this take some
no it doesn't matter about cooking is
adding your own sound effects would let
it gently because he's already French
cut oh yeah well they're very proud like
Barefoot Contessa just folding in here
the colors in the mutant puke tone
colors we may need some a little tiny
bit of milk we need milk what kind
we need 3/4 cup of milk three Porter's
cup of milk we need no okay so what do
we do we have to get them all right we
need mousse mono please be all right
I shall consult refrigerator as the
refrigerator for hasn't enough for us
it's just today's date you think it's
gonna we're gonna start a cooking show
called the best we can do it smells fine
because I never don't know about that
it's just small by date do it that's a
lot little baby
interesting thing about green bean
casserole the interesting thing about
green bean casserole
guess what it never happens it's a
resolution we know and dishwasher open
by itself there's a ghost 1/8 teaspoon
of black pepper how to even measure my
majestic estimate I usually sprinkle em
in my hand first see oh that's too much
Brad we need the French onions climb up
see all of them watch all of the damn
song I need to save something out
crunchy tomorrow ok this is my favorite
part
and quite honestly arguably the reason
that this whole dish is so delicious
oh my god well then I won't hog the boys
yes but you need to save some for the
topic right now feed evenly blend blend
blend that's good
that looks what thing can you tell that
my mom is a teacher like the way my dog
gets trained it's all positive
reinforcement where's your Jeff right
now in a garden where's your Jeff right
now now we are going to watch bake it
and then a few minutes before baking
process is complete we will top and
brown the top all right then you better
put these in some lock I will say stays
yeah so that they're inside to put on
them before they get then to the oven to
the oven and away how do we get it in
there Oh God Jackie green bean update
what's happening with them mmm
oh we got a crisis in the kitchen we got
a full-on crisis who knows how the beans
are gonna turn out this is do or die the
only thing I do know is that they're
trying to hide the crunchy onion topping
from me
something's beeping oh no oh no oh no
it's just pan like full panic oh we're
back we gotta check the green beans oh
my god what's happening where there they
are right there
look I'm they look great they look
really yeah mom is genuinely surprised
that we did something productive
together so now we put the rest of the
topping on yeah this we're gonna wait
ohh
get cooking is the worst I'm being told
the green beans are being finished okay
how do they look I think they look
amazing
Wow Wow we get to do this okay hey
that's happening
they look bull jeez how we gonna cook
for 5 more minutes what we're gonna wait
till our guests arrive okay okay
and are you saving any of the toppings
yeah did the Queen Linda Jules yeah I
just every time I come back something's
different I did my hair I had a jewelry
and I can't make a decision I can decide
them that crunchy topping go